every week layla and i my wife talked to
five to ten new companies to potentially
invest in that have already passed a
couple rounds of screening and i was on
a conversation the other day with a
coaching business and the founder made a
very ridiculous statement and i thought
i would make a video about it because i
think you'll get a lot of value from it
they made the statement i just don't
think there's a way that we can make our
customers more valuable uh which as you
can imagine if you've been following my
channel for a while you know drove me
into a fit of rage not really but i i
stopped and i wish i had recorded it but
the basic premise is that that's just
patently false and i'll show you six
different ways you can increase lifetime
value in a coaching or service based
business all right and so if you don't
know who i am my name is alex mosey i
own acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that right now does about 110
million dollars a year and continuing to
grow and so i have nothing to sell you i
just make these videos because
i hope you get value from them okay so
there are there are two ways that you
grow a business right number one is you
get more customers the second is you
make them worth more that's it that's
chunked all the way up at the top of
this right like either get more
customers you make them worth more all
right there's lots of sub buckets
underneath of that but those are the two
fundamentals if you're attacking a
business in terms of like trying to
figure out how you want to grow your own
business you can use these mental
frameworks and so these are kind of like
my own checklist of what i'm thinking
through or someone's talking because we
only have 15 to 20 minutes with these
new companies because we talk to a lot
of them just to get a feel if we want to
invest time and money into them so that
being said with this particular company
it was a coaching business now the nice
thing is that with coaching businesses
it really applies to all types of
businesses so if you're a service-based
business if you coach for weight loss
that is a service business if you you
know a lot of businesses just don't like
the term coaching but it is more or less
what you're doing you're advising
clients on some sort of outcome right
and so um in this particular business
they said that they didn't have a way of
you know making the customer more
valuable and so these are the six ways
that you can make a customer more
valuable and i'll give the example that
i shared with them to try to drive it
home alright so if you can think about
this within your own business you will
make more money so the first and obvious
one is you can raise prices so you can
sell the exact same thing and add money
to it and make more money sounds wild
but that is something that a lot of
people don't do and so getting the
pricing right is a way of making more
money there are sub-pieces that we could
sell higher percentages of people by
having different pricing levels but just
big picture number one is you can
increase the price number two is that
you can lower the cost of goods right
because we're looking at how can we make
a customer more valuable we can make
that by raising the price but we can
also lower how much it costs to fulfill
on them and so there's two easy ways you
can do this within a coaching business
one is that you could decrease the cost
of the people themselves so you keep the
ratio that you have with your clients
but then you probably outsource a
component of that uh you know to
somebody who might be abroad who'd be
willing to work for less money all right
that would be a way of decreasing the
cost of goods the other way of
decreasing the cost of goods is keeping
the same number of coaches but
increasing the ratio between coaches to
clients if one coach is managing 10
clients and then they go to managing 20
clients your cost of goods cuts in half
right and in so doing that your margin
goes up hopefully you're tracking with
me so number one increase the price
number two decrease the cost of goods
number three is increase the purchase
velocity or frequencies the number of
times people buy all right and so within
the context of a recurring revenue
business that would be decreasing churn
though getting people to stick and stay
and pay longer right so if somebody
normally buys and then stays for three
months in your you know service-based
business or coaching business or
whatever it is then if we can get them
to stay just an additional month it's a
25 increase in ltv so how much that
person is worth to us over the lifetime
of them being with us right and so
number one price two cost of goods
number three getting them to buy more
times the other whole next three buckets
all kind of fall they're different
flavors of the same thing all right and
so it's cross sells upsells and down
cells and so i'll give examples of each
of those so cross sales is when you have
them buy something and then buy a
different thing as in a as an add-on all
right so if you have a level of service
uh let's say you have a coaching
business right because i'm using the
example that we were talking about if
they if they have a core service but
there's an element of something that uh
someone needs to do so let's say they're
doing some sort of business coaching
right a lot of times they're going to
have some sort of model that they're
helping people execute within their
business or
flip to and then there's sub components
of the execution so there might be
creating ads that would be an add-on
service that you could add it could be
drilling their their sales team right so
helping them train their sales or train
themselves on sales because they need
that additional level of support and so
just think about the different
bottlenecks that people are experiencing
within the execution of the core
business that not necessarily everyone
will use but some people would get a
tremendous amount of value from those
are kind of perfect scenarios for
add-ons that you can add to the service
levels that will increase the lifetime
value because let's say twenty percent
of people take uh an upsell you know of
an extra thousand dollars a month and
they're paying a thousand dollars a
month well just like that you took your
average monthly from a thousand to
twelve hundred right so it's a twenty
percent increase because you got twenty
percent of people to take an additional
uh level of service all right the second
type of sell here so i said there's six
ways so we've covered four price cost of
goods increasing purchase frequency
cross sells the next one is upsells all
right so i like to delineate this from
cross sales cross sales is selling a
different thing to the same customer all
right so in the mcdonald's version this
is like would you like fries with your
coke right or whatever it is fries with
your burger doesn't matter but like it's
the crossover selling something
different that still goes with the core
thing an upsell is where you sell more
of the thing that they just bought so
this is where in i'll use the mcdonald's
example to drive it home and then i'll
give you a coaching example so in the
mcdonald's example it's would you like
you want a burger do you want a bigger
burger right that would be an upsell
right it's the same but more of the same
thing and it's good to think through
these these frameworks because this is
how you can think of and iterate your
own service levels within the business
so let's say that somebody in this
coaching business you know meets with
their coach every whatever every every
two weeks we could increase that
frequency and say okay well like our
higher level of service you can meet
with the coach more times right or you
could have it's more access whatever the
thing that we're selling is it's just
more of it and you'd be surprised a lot
of people just want more and this is
where this gets kind of interesting from
uh from a from a pricing and
lifetime value perspective customers are
fractal and what that means is that it's
80 20. so one out of five customers is
typically willing to pay twice as much
as the core offer that continues to go
up so if you know if you have 100 people
20 of them are willing to pay five times
you know as much as the the base adr
which then means that if you get 20 to
take something that's five times as
expensive then you actually just double
the lifetime value now if you look at
that 20 and look again and do another 80
20 split on that then four of those 20
are going to be willing to pay another
five times more than the remaining 16 in
that group right 80 20. and so it
continues to get fractal so it's like 80
20 95 5 9 1 all of those are fractal
distributions and with each of those
increments you usually have people who
have significantly higher spending power
and so simply offering a significantly
more expensive version to 20 of the
customers is typically a really good way
of increasing ltv all right and so in
this coaching example if they had a
large group component and they wanted to
do a semi-private component or small
group then that would be something that
should reasonably be you know probably
four or five times as expensive given
the fact that it's now significantly
more narrow and more attention is given
to each customer all right so increase
the price increase uh decrease the cost
of goods get people to buy more times
sell them more stuff that's different
sell them more of the same all right
cross sells upsells and the last one
number six is downsells all right so
this is when in in the purpose of the
down cell there's kind of two two key
areas in the business where this is
helpful number one is on the front end
number two is on the back end all right
so on the front end getting more down
cells it's i'll tell you where it
backfires but if you have another
offering for people who get on the phone
it's especially useful and this is how
you do it right for disqualified or
under qualified leads all right because
you've already paid for the marketing to
get this person on the phone or into
your kind of conversion event but if the
person does not qualify for your core
offer because they don't meet certain
you know
requirements that you've already
predefined of like what a perfect
customer is for you then you want to
have something for them that can help
them ascend into that that's going to be
significantly lower touch or ideally no
touch at all right and so in this
instance i think this was a health
coaching thing they i was like just
create a done for you at home or done do
it yourself at home program that people
who can't afford to have the level of
service they get a little bit of a head
start they get a little bit of education
to get them going so that they can then
you know if they succeed with that they
show themselves they're motivated they
show themselves this is more valuable
than then they can ascend up where it
gets sticky is where you have people who
otherwise would have bought the core
offer but then the sales team starts
down selling them that's the no no
that's what you don't want to have
happen and that's why tracking before
you make it like implement a downsell
into your sales process is important
because you can see the percentage of
people who are buying the core offer and
so we should just simply be adding on
more sales without detracting from the
amount of people who are buying the core
offer the second way that we protect
against this is that when you have the
customer requirements if someone meets
the customer requirements for your core
offer they should never be presented the
downsell that is in my opinion that's
how i prefer to do it because it also
keeps it black and white for the sales
team so because you don't want to have
gray in making sales decisions in my
opinion i think it's much easier to say
like if they are this sell this if they
are not this sell this that way we're
just treating the customer for what was
best for them rather than trying to like
go based on their budget this is me
personally because i just want to say
like if i'm going to make this promise
to you i'm going to fulfill this promise
to you period and if we need to find a
way for you to get the resources to do
it then we will help you do that but
like we're not going to just give you a
deluded version of what we had right and
so it's only like if you do not qualify
then and only then will we down sell the
reason this is effective is that you
have these people you've already paid to
get on the phone and so if you can
liquidate a certain percentage of that
cost by having a down sell it will help
you offset cost of acquisition and
ultimately make some more money and you
also get more customers because those
people have potential in the future
which is a great thing now the other
place where down cells help is actually
on the back end so information declines
in value over time right and a lot of
businesses that we work with are
e-learning service coaching et cetera
types of businesses and so one of the
difficulties is how do they uh attack
churn and so part of the way of
attacking churn is realizing how people
are consuming value through the services
that they offer right and so if someone
you know the day before you learn
something very important it's incredibly
valuable the day after it you don't need
to learn it again because you already
have it so the value declines very very
precipitously um in these types of
businesses which is what we've spent you
know our life kind of fixing and making
them more valuable right but having a
downsell component on the back end when
people are like you know what i've
gotten a lot from this you know i don't
i don't need the training and all that
kind of stuff anymore what it is the
question is what do they need or what
would they like to keep right and a lot
of times community access is something
that people will continue to pay for
even though they're not access to the
information anymore because like they
don't need it because they already
they've already figured it out right um
or certain levels of troubleshooting and
support whether it be technical support
or accountability level support those
are things that are are consumable right
in terms of like you might need to be
held accountable last month and you need
to be held accountable this month um
towards doing the actions and so when we
think about this and we're looking at a
business and this was the the coaching
business that i'll give you as an
example hopefully those answers uh give
you some light depending on what type of
business you have but there are always
ways to make a customer more more
valuable over time and so those are the
six um that i think through when i'm
looking at any kind of coaching info
service type business that we're looking
to take on which is like where do we see
opportunity that we can increase the ltv
per customer so that we can then turn
around and spend to get more customers
on the front end right because if we're
chunking back up two ways to get more uh
make more money get more customers make
them worth more and that is a wrap so uh
thank you guys appreciate if you're new
to mozy nation welcome i appreciate you
and i'll see you guys in the next video
bye